[Music]
hey baby we going to be here all day we
going to be here all day baby I like
this kind of party welcome back to the
way back I'm Ryan sickler Ryan sickler
and Ryan sichler on all your social
media very excited to have my guest here
on the way back ladies and gentlemen Ari
shafir welcome to the way back give me
one please give
me excited excited they do it for you to
they G
you we got
all the fcking truckers yeah that's when
you weren't like shooting a bird at
somebody we do that every now and then
they pull up on the side my dad's like
what are yall doing back there what
flipping somebody off yeah and they pull
us all back up there I figured you'd be
the first person that would moon on this
podcast I never no we weren't those kids
like that we W well I want to ask you
this is what I want to ask you first so
well you said you actually cuz you are
old enough you one of so many dude the
carps you you want the back did your um
Family own a wagon I would too I think I
would too get sick going backward I
can't sit on a train like that I got to
ride the way why do they even have those
on the train yeah I can't do that on a
train yeah the gorland had one s the
back G the gorland yeah and then they
had two types the ones that flipped down
and the ones mostly that opened up yeah
that's right and you get that back it
was so dangerous you get rear endered
those kids are dead dead no seat belts
no nothing yeah slam slam smash that's
what this seat's all about right here
yeah you don't have seat belts it's so
funny cuz um I love the seat but who was
it Kirsten that said um was it
Florentine maybe that the better you
were behaved the closer you got to sit
to the front he said he never got past
the middle seat we used to fight in the
back seat so much my parents would we
would we would uh we would do this thing
where we'd mess with each other we' be
like you know You' tap tap hit hit hit
and then your parents like stop it's
done and You' like like I got you
last they like stop it and like just I'm
not touching you I'm not touching you
but like I got you last and we had a
song for it like I got you L I got you
last I got you L and then uh and then
they like you cut it out back there and
then like okay fine like y
MCA y they knew like she's thring it I'm
like it's just a hit song I can't sing a
hit song of the era and they'd be so bad
you know what this is what I want to ask
you because I know you as a person as an
adult person you've created a show
called amazing R oh yeah you have I was
going to say you were on that but you
were on a different show I was on a you
have pulled your hemorrhoid kleenexes
out on podcast you wiped microphones up
your ass you've drug your friends in
front of their kids you not in front of
their kids kid are safely inside taking
shots at none the wiser what was did
were you aing practical joker growing up
or was this all later like I think it
was all waiting like the amount of like
what's your origin story like where does
that I'm the same as B you come from no
I'm just like I was just a well-to-do
kid I was a joker in like in like grade
school and stuff joking people you're
just being funny person you weren't you
weren't doing any wild yeah and I was
just like same with with girls like once
I started having sex 23 I was just a
[__] for a while the make up for lost
time oh yeah you lost a lot of time yeah
girls and drugs it was like let's catch
up but it was like way later and
somebody's like do you think it's that
because you're so repressed I'm like
probably yeah I didn't get into any of
that stuff Orthodox Jewish upbringing
right and so talk me about your school
cuz I highly doubt there's going to be
many guests that sit here with an
Orthodox Jewish upbringing so is it all
boy school or was it mixed schools uh
the religious classes were boys and then
the girls would do their own uh um um we
were a mixed high school so you would
just separate for those classes Shiva
high was uh all boys and then they had a
girls depart like another school another
place yeah in Maryland in Silver Spring
you were allowed to wear shorts up until
fourth grade and then like that's it for
that and then you had to wear a collared
shirt long pants if you were just a
sweater you like got to have a collar
under that really some guys would be
like Rebels and they like tape an old
collar underneath
it a the system
dude Rebel Without a Cause so tell me
about these kids cuz look this seems
like very strict it seems obviously it's
Orthodox so but kids are kids kids are
kids kids are kids so what do you guys
know it was strict we had no idea it was
stct I saw Coolio on the old John
Stewart show before The Daily Show he
had a UPN show no UPN oh wow do you
remember that one uhuh I remember the
MTV one it was the John Stewart show and
I went to a taping of it I'll never
forgive my buddy for this AI went to a
taping they shot a [__] Cannon or at
least thre a shirt I don't remember how
they got it a rolled up John Stewart
shirt and I was like looked it right in
my hand and the last second he goes nope
and he just grabbed it oh he got it I'm
so [__] mad he's not he's of style I
would have rocked it so well but he had
Coolio on and he goes it must have been
tough having to deal with
driveby stuff like that people may be
shooting you trying to inundate you into
a gang and he go Coolio goes no man it
was just as a kid you're your level so
what in my world a driveby took the same
place as your world where a bully took
your lunch money it was the same level
of danger right so it was that we had a
blast we had our friends we we do
whatever we thought was we didn't think
we were missing on anything you know so
yeah we never touched women and kissed
women but well I asked you about high
school dances and you said no that
wasn't even allowed at your school so we
had a couple okay some of the more LAX
parents no alcohol I mean no alcohol
well your kids yeah but I mean even even
a 16 17 18 like sneak [__] no it wasn't
even a thought no one had even seen weed
I was like we heard of it my sister went
to a Pink Floyd show when I was like in
sixth grade she was in eighth she goes
you could smell marijuana I'm telling
you you could smell it it was there it
was there yeah it was there yeah the
[__] was like no way what do you mean
where would they do it I remember my
first concert
ever you're in Maryland bro Merryweather
Post
Pavilion I'm seventh grade my buddy
Jason daneli he was the kid in our class
that was allowed to cuss in front of his
parents dude my face too first time we
was like that's [__] Dad we were
like oh you about to get [__] up he
was allowed to say whatever he wanted to
as long as it wasn't [__] wow so his
brother introduces us to Metallica and
now Metallica is coming to open for Azie
at Merryweather Post Pavilion it was the
ultimate sin tour
1987 Metallica's On The Master of
Puppets store they're still young kids
wow they're about to blow up right and I
get to see Cliff Burton before he dies
this is weeks before he passes away so
his parents were down he's like you guys
got to go me and my brother are like can
we go my parents are like [__] no and
then his dad calls and they talk and
he's like look I'm going to drive him
there
I'm going to drop them off at the gate
they're going to go into their assigned
seats and I'm going to wait there he's
at Columbia Mall he's like I'm going to
come they'll come right back to the car
and my parents agree so our first
concert is Aussie
Osborne Metallica's opening Cliff Burton
James headfield is has a broken arm from
skateboarding so the guitar text that's
how young these guys still are wow damn
I just know him as this old man battling
Napster yeah wow that's right there it
is it was at 86 there you go 1986 August
2nd yep that's a a month and a half
later there you go wow we got to see him
right before that what did he die of
they had a they had a no no they had a
bus crash it rolled over there's a whole
story about like James Hadfield like
almost like that La Bomba [__] and he
didn't want to sleep near a window cuz
his throat he needed to protect his
throat to sing so Cliff said I will and
then they hit like some black ice but
the bus rolled and he fell out and then
the the bus fell on him and crushed him
he was 24 years old yeah all this say
the my first time seeing smelling
touching marijuana cuz my my parents are
like someone's got to stick a needle in
you and I'm like even then I was like no
one's going to waste their Dr yeah what
the [__] are you talking about my mom
was like you can't go to rap concert you
got trampled that blue row right here
this is like our seats this last row
right here wow and on my right we start
to smell weed and we're like oh my God
we're terrified we're in seventh God
coming down the row oh they're passing
it they're passing a joint Jo the whole
way and it comes to me and I just grab
that [__] pass it to my brother
he passed it to Dani and on it kept
going can scared to death so scared can
I even will it come through my hand am i
g to get high from touching I heard
Jimmy hend would get high during shows
yeah oh my God oh my God can I tell you
you knew then what some [__] dorks
don't know now when they're passing
around and it C to you go no thanks just
pass it just pass it you don't have to
smoke nobody gives a [__] if you're
smoking the guy on your left KNE it just
let me facilitate yep [__] idiots
terrified touching it like wow wow mine
was Constitution Hol your rhythmics with
my sister and you saw it no I didn't no
I just made first concert I don't think
there was any there I remember the
smells sweet leaf it's such a sweet
smell in the air I love it so
specific the first time I smelled crack
was in a Winnipeg and I was like who's
burning
candy what's going on
um but but I also asked you so you said
you had a couple dances but I asked you
were you ever invited by a girl from
another school where you could go there
yeah so so JDS was like the less
religious school I eventually switched
there in 11th grade I wanted to change
even then my rebellious attitude was
like I want to move around that's the
same reason I went from LA to New York
and I'll go from New York onwards you
know it's like I I just want new
experiences and I wanted this new what's
it like a
JDS um but there was a girl there was on
my block uh Jenny from From the Block
actually her name was Jenny but uh so
she came to one of the the Hebrew
Academy dance parties and we'd
occasionally dance with the more laxed
parents but but you have to go like this
you hold them high waist this far and
they put their their arms on you on your
shoulders there's clear distance between
you and then it was like every once in a
while it be a slow song you're like oh
wow can I get a girl so Jenny had this
crush on her I was like do you want a
slow dance you know the slow song do you
she goes sure yeah she's used to these
[__] JDS dances so I go to this and
she comes right in and gives me the the
this oh and I was just like what the
[__] she must have felt my 2in dick at
the 3
in I mean I mean I was never and I was
just like don't [__] it up don't [__] it
up and it was just like w you put your
arms around her and it was like is this
what dancing is like is this what
adulthood is like I got to switch to JDS
it was that was probably sixth or
seventh grade it got in my head it was
wild later JDS those girls as adults
were bad kids bad kids yeah they smoked
weed they drank um they had a I was in
the other room they had a Spanish sword
fight what the hell's that I don't know
this one dicks obviously but what's a
Spanish sword fight what do you do with
this one three
girls three guys are sitting next to
each other three girls are having a
contest to see who can get their guy off
first that's a Spanish sword fight I
guess
so I mean first last time I heard of it
to be honest I never really researched
if it was a real thing I'll be honest
with you I don't know but that's what
they called it I was the other room
watching Beav and
Butthead I was like wait you guys did
what like you know whatever it happens
like that doesn't just happen that
doesn't just happen I never had any of
that wild [__] like I hear these guys
out here on the West Coast tell me that
[__] they were doing in seventh grade
I'm like we weren't doing anything like
that high school was like man if you
touched a girl's boob over her sweater
over the sweater you were over the moon
you were like why like kissing you have
your hand here and like I'll go to the
belly or I'll go to the the the the um
waist but you instead of going like that
you're like let me try it and you just
rip by and if they don't like Revolt
you're like I think they might want to
do back and they like I'll go back to
next rip ey again and they're like I
think I'm in and they're like wow a girl
perfume did you wear a clog were you car
Noir yeah for real I did I never did I
saw probably one commercial and I was
hooked I did a your car for 10 seconds
and then a girlfriend gave me Obsession
by Calvin Klein interesting Polo was a
big one everyone more Polo Obsession
yeah and cool water cool water Obsession
that was like yeah there's that oval
bottle wow and then um Tuscany I wore
Tuscany for a second to you still wear
clone no deod I hav't wor clothes since
this [__] right here I gave up deodorant
for like six months this year um jakar
let's see that jakar bottle black bottle
[Music]
right couple spritzes and one on the
walkth through like Sebastian says
couple of the neck one on the walkth
through is that Sebastian or Brett erns
I forget either one of them it could be
yeah maybe BR and then the girls would
tell you put it on your pulse pules and
it'll emate for phones yeah Polo was big
it was like the original old one the
green one yeah that thing right there
everybody had that by
Fab that's Eddie Murphy's joke you gave
your dad brute for he's like brute by
Fab you cheap [__] who the
[__] Fab why do you have to say by Fab
that's what the whole thing was it's
like promoted by it's like Live Nation
Live Nation of cologne brute by Fab you
still have those songs stuck in your
head from back then I have um stuck on B
I'm stuck on band
on we are Flintstone kids 10,000 strong
and growing or whatever strong and gr
right 10 million strong and growing you
know what song's in my head from back
then and I think it was just Maryland
junry means Fight For Life nobody bother
me dude nobody bother me either
yes
[Laughter]
yes you got to look that up see if you
can find that old commercial oh my God J
N that's it oh that's it dude I L I have
not thought of that and it's still in
there it's still in there I thought of
that commercial for decades training
little kids this guy was fighting
[__] ninjas and in
Saigon and then he he taught
seven-year-olds how to fight look at
this look at
[Music]
him
selfdefense then you two can say
yeah
NOS get lady no
BS that's right
do 1,000 that was the number
and means fight for nobody buys me no bu
terrible
editing I forgot about that commercial
you can tell they already roll the film
like say it say it now say it now kid
say it say it say it um all right let
see if you remember this guy Captain
Chesapeake did you ever have did you
remember this dude Captain Chesapeake
yeah Captain chesp was big in Maryland
he was the captain he had like a morning
TV he was like a Mr Rogers there he is
and and that's the sea monster back
there oh yeah oh yeah Captain ches look
how long he had a run from 71 to 90 aoy
crew members there he is right there
yeah wow what happened to Captain I
don't know what happened to Captain
Chesapeake okay so I I've told this
story before you'll know this one too so
back when Atari came out right it first
came out everyone in one I remember that
you had a joystick and a button dude my
buddy pulled fogger Pitfall he pulled it
out no he pulled the suction cup or the
grip off the controller and put it on
his forehead and just as a joke when he
took it off he had a [__] hickey he
had to wear Band-Aids to cover it yeah
this is it that's it came and one 2600
it was the best it changed everybody's
life it some people had kico and you're
like you're a dork yeah this was before
yes this was it right here when this
came out you had Pitfall Donkey Kong
River ra Pac-Man all of them right um
one button it was shoot and move and you
would we won and won so bad my dad was
like we can't afford that or whatever so
reset so this guy what a is doing a
contest on W now we're in we're in
Maryland so we're we got the Baltimore
channels and the DC Channel okay he's DC
and they're doing a contest that's the
dude Diesel and they're giving away an
Atari right and we're like what and
every like it might have been one once a
week he would come on they'd have a
wheel and they'd spin it and you had to
submit a postcard that had your name
address phone number and your favorite
show right and the show ranges were like
Scooby-Doo The Jeffersons good time San
Franc we're watching all that [__] back
in the day so we me and my two brothers
sit down and we submit hundreds of them
we're wrri Scooby-Doo we're just submit
the [__] out of yeah just overload the
system and one night it's like a
Wednesday night we're all everyone in
elementary school we're in like third
grade everyone is dialed in cuz
everyone's submitting for this thing we
all want aari and they're like all right
we're pulling our next contestant and
they pull it out and they're like Derek
sickler and we're like
what and we are jumping up and down like
[__] it [__] yeah we got a shot at Atari
Derek sickler of Eldersburg Maryland so
he spins the way and he's like
Scooby-Doo is his favorite show dude
spins the [__] wheel and the balls
bouncing and bouncing and bouncing and
it goes right to Scooby-Doo and then it
goes right next to Scooby-Doo and we
[__] lose and I'm like
oh damn next day we go to school my
brother's a goddamn celebrity because he
got everyone's watching you know wow oh
yeah yeah they're like we're going to
send you a t-shirt as a consolation
prize like I seriously like six months
later that [__] t-shirt showed up my
dad felt so bad like we were so gutted
that he went and got the damn Atari yeah
he did he could he could he couldn't
bear see it was devastated dude was huge
oh wait you said you remembered a car
commercial or a commercial you said I
remembered yeah it's not right for this
good
Feelgood is it a dead one is it a seven
it was for Down syndrome stuff
here's one so um let your fingers do the
walking let your fingers do the walking
yeah yeah remember that let your fingers
do the walking so we had a red
Volkswagen Beetle at the time it was
beat up from the 70s so the Yellow Pages
they did a whole ad campaign where you
could paint your car they would paint
your car yellow pick your color no we
went blue and you had to put their logo
on like the hood and the doors and the
trunk for like a year or 6 months and
then they're going to peel that off and
you get a new paint job that was the ad
thing they did well my parents did this
[__] for what cuz we had no money and
they wanted a new paint job they peel
that [__] off you could clearly see the
outline you know what I mean it was
horrible it was horrible dude and every
now and then on the freeway be like
there goes one you know not many of them
out there bro not many of out there so
we have this shitty Volkswagen and my
mom enters a contest it was the um WP
plays it country 93.1 I think they were
WP plays it country we would never
listen to country music then we didn't
either but my mom did cuz she was
sleeping with a dude that listen to
country music cheating on my dad she's
watching so um she enters this radio
contest where they are taking 99 99 WPC
99 contestants to um the Harbor and
they're going to have a brand new Dodge
Chrysler Laser and the window's going to
be down on the driver's side and they
have to get I don't know how many feet
but I don't know if they did like 99 ft
or what but you had to throw a football
into the window of the car and if you
did you'd win the [__] car and we're
like all we do is play sports we're so
[__] we're and my mom doesn't ever
[__] consult us talk to us nothing
nothing we're like are you practicing
are you [__] practicing during the
day she's like I'm like on your lunch
break go out in that Park
like this thing the girls do where they
shift their whole body shot put it yeah
so we're down there it's dark it's the
Inner Harbor it's a whole thing's going
on the radio thing 99 people are lined
up and I'm telling you I don't remember
but we're in the back back chunk where
it might be in the 80s yeah but there's
this one [__] dude I still remember
this guy goodlooking dude he's over on
the side the whole time he's throwing
with his buddy the whole time practicing
getting the whole time no one makes it
now if we go through all 99 people they
reset it again and you get to go again
car moving nope sitting still bro
sitting [__] still so here comes my
mom nobody's one yet my mom throws this
[__] ball it goes like five [__]
bro it's a microcosm of everything it
just goes we're like are you [__] kid
like we're kids looking at our mom going
are you [__] kidding me right now and
who's behind us [__] Johnny U over
here has been practicing and what does
Johnny U do right in the [__] window
bro so now mom's out you know what I'm
saying but the other people behind could
still tie it and go for it second round
nobody does you know what Johnny U does
after he throws it in the window what
goes right off to the [__] side and
continues to throw in case in case wow
homeboy stayed [__] ready and we went
back home in that goddamn Yellow Pages
you a
lesson he taught you a valuable lesson
he did I was like that guy I'm like do
you see this guy stay sharp through
finish yeah be like him tell me um tell
me about baseball cards yeah I get them
all the time we all my friends we we had
them my my gems were a George Brett
rookie card that I stole from my friend
okay I was going to say you open that
nope it was on he was counting all the
stuff I stole it from him still kind of
regret it but also not so much um and
then Frank Thomas I got way into early
Frank Thomas the big heart I had all his
rookie cards what nickname too the Big
Hurt and he'd put that hurt on you he
[__] did dude that son of [__] I
remember I was working at Woodmont
Country Club I was like 16 and there was
a Mike muc was pitching for the Orioles
and he pitched a one hitter and they
lost one nothing on a home run to Frank
Thomas he also pitched one against
Cleveland where Sandy Alamar broke it up
in like the ninth he four no or one
hitters four one hitters he was that
[__] close to four no hitters Mike m
did he ever throw a perfect game go up
there I don't think he did I don't think
he ever got a no hitter or a perfect
game two outs of a perfect game and one
out that was the one I think that Sandy
Alamar got the base hit and ruined it
that's how goody people don't realize
dude 41 hits that's crazy wow oh he's
Hall of Fame he deserves it yeah no
doubt he deserves it damn damn yeah we
had all these cards you just were you or
fan growing up no I was a Yankee fan
Yanke but we went to see the Orioles
that wtp had some stuff where they' play
the Orioles would play basketball
against against like maybe the maybe the
the the Redskins oh like a charity event
charity event yeah and Cal ripen was
there playing
basketball Cal nobody remembers they
always taught you do not throw like him
he throws sidearm they tell every kid
now like don't because they all try to
emulate him they're like that's bad form
don't do that uh they were good though
when I was younger the orals had a
chance and they were like right in the
did they win a title back then 96 97s
you're thinking of when they Alamar and
Eddie Murray came back they were really
good but they got knocked out yeah um
but they weren't 83 was their year 96 97
they were good that's how long they
sucked in between and then they weren't
good again until last year out of
nowhere out of nowhere yeah the O's were
really good Memorial Stadium sucked and
first time I've ever heard did you hear
that Kiren that came out that's one of
the greatest national anthems is like
you know say by the start BL what did
they get to say can you see and
everybody goes oh I my daughter it's so
cool I'll do that again disrespectful
and [__] like no it's adding respect
you're already singing the National
Anthem also the song was written in that
City yeah Frederick Maryland no Francis
Scott Key wrote Scott at the Frederick
Keys Fort McKenry yeah wow you're right
Fort McKenry so [__] off we can do
whatever we want that's what I'm saying
we made this song how the hell is that
how the hell why don't we get some more
respect we need to do an All-Star team
of comics from Maryland Miu
stav I I think Chappelle he's I think
yeah Martin Lawrence Martin Lawrence
M's Maryland Jos Master's Maryland we're
going to forget somebody Francisco Ramos
is Maryland really who else Chelle
probably be starter yeah I would say so
there's oh uh Lewis Black oh yeah um
Patton oswal he might be Virginia but I
feel like he's right there in that
pocket yeah there's a lot of really good
talented but we're missing someone be
[__] we had at finals at Hebrew
Academy and they were giving away a
ticket to a bullets game two tickets to
a bullets game Mr marker said it love
the PE guy and uh me and Kim zackheim
and enterprising young youths young
Jewish youths we're like let's go to the
game they give it away it was probably
against the Bucks I think who were
sucked at the time long before they
[__] went to Greece to
recruit yeah right and uh on the way we
were like oh let's let's go it's like
well I got two you got two that mean you
have two extra ones and then it hit us
like let's scalp and so every single
person that came out of finals cuz
that's when they had like 5,000 people
to 25,000 say you know the old Cap
Center and we're like hey you going to
go to that game you use new ticket can
we have them if you're not use them like
yeah sure I'm not going to go great a
couple people like I might go it's like
fine whatever we got them all got 35
tickets and we went out there we [__]
scalp tickets all day [__] yeah you sell
them all sell them all do you remember
what face value are below get the we'll
go below they still have tickets
available we're undercutting them
outside we got them for free we made
hundreds that's actually not scalping
it's the opposite of that's true you're
right you're right you're right you're
right you're
right that's just legal selling you're
right that's just that's just yeah
exactly we were so worried we trouble I
thought we got chased out of there but
that might be a false memory Diaz did
that once at the store The Story Goes
they would give out Comics the store was
struggling The Comedy Store and they
were like hey tell you what if you come
in contact with anybody and you mention
The Comedy Store so here's two free
tickets to anybody we'll get them in
we'll get drinks off them put your
initials on them and then we'll give you
$2 if one of your initials tickets come
back you know just if you're out at
where you worked at uh you know at the
Beverly Center or the uh you know H and
Highland anywhere just like give back to
people playing golf with some give them
out they come back $2 why not and Diaz
just got his idea like sweet so there
was a line to get in on a Saturday night
he goes don't pay here don't pay here
don't pay here so they'd lose $20 each
and he $2 each they lose $22 on each
person and they're like all right we
can't do this
anymore Diaz exploits weaknesses in your
security yes dude thank you for doing
this this was fun this is a fun one it
takes you back this one takes you back
this a good one get you stories you
never even thought of um please plug and
uh I got a new podcast myself similar to
this there stories you don't think of
it's a travel podcast one hour one place
pretty much it's called you be tripping
it's available anywhere take you to some
magical spots in the world um through
people that have been there not really
travel like what to do but like what
people got into while they were there
it'll get you get you wanting to get out
yourself and then I'm touring on the
road we're alongside of history tours
out now be in Australia Denver and
Toronto and all all over all over from
South Carolina all the way up to Toronto
on a bus with colum Terrell and somebody
else I got to find somebody else all
right yeah but this was great man great
to see you again what a good excuse to
see a friend nice of you thank you I
know you made a lot of uh travel
arrangements to be here thank you
princess St for hour all for you
princess let's see this trick can we do
it do it girl oh you getting the belly
oh give him a kiss princess give him a
kiss as always Ryan sickler on all your
social media ryan.com come see me on
tour I'll talk to you'all next
week
[Music]
I